Speaker 1: Hey, this is fascinating news, and many
of you, I know, will take great pleasure in this.
Alex Jones Infowars has filed for bankruptcy.
Now I'm going to tell you right up front.
This stinks to high heaven, and you're going
to start to figure out why in a moment,
but here's the report from Reuters
far right wing website Infowars
yesterday Sunday filed for voluntary
Chapter 11 bankruptcy protection
in the face of multiple defamation lawsuits.
Chapter 11 bankruptcy puts a hold on all civil
litigation matters and allows companies to prepare
turnaround plans while remaining operational.
Alex Jones, founder of Infowars, was found liable
for damages in a trio of lawsuits last year after
he falsely claimed the 2012 Sandy Hook School
massacre was a hoax. Jones claimed the shooting,
in which 20 children and six school employees
were shot dead, was fabricated by gun control
advocates. Sandy Hook families in late March
rejected his offer to settle and reopen the case.
Jones offered to pay 120 grand to each of the 13
plaintiffs. Each of the plaintiffs turned it down.
Infowars listed its estimated assets in the range
of zero to $50000 and estimated liabilities in
the range of one to 10 million dollars. Infowars
reportedly made a $165 million over three years,
according to records. So right away, many of you
emailed me with the exact thought that I had.
Is this a fraudulent bankruptcy? Has money just
been moved and moved and moved and difficult to
track ways? And now Alex Jones is saying, We don't
have any money and we're bankrupt and we're not
going to be able to pay anybody. Is that really
what's going on? I don't know. It does stink.
And if you have revenues of one hundred and sixty
five million over three years, $50000, you know,
that's a rounding error. It is difficult
to believe that a company with a, you know,
50 million, $55 million a year in revenue
doesn't even have 50 grand in cash on hand. Now,
he claims that liabilities are between one
and $10 million. So is it possible that all
of the legal fees have drained the Infowars
reserves? I don't know. But it smells very,
very funky. If there is any real false flag
operation, it's more likely that it's Alex
Jones lying about not having any more money than
it is the things he said about Sandy Hook. So
hopefully the court will assign a forensic
accountant to look at if and when money was moved
because he knew the court was going to take
the money and give it to people in settlements.
It is not if you have competent counsel, lawyers
and accountants, it's it's shockingly easy
to make money disappear into a
black hole of overseas accounts,
and it would really take a lot of work to track it
down. So I don't know what's going on. It would be
in some sense, delightful to see such a corrosive
media influence no longer be financially viable.
And when I say that, it's like, you know, I
don't wish for people to get covered and die.
I don't wish for people to be unable to
feed themselves by not having any money.
But the world would be better off without Infowars
and without Alex Jones supplements being sold,
and that's a large share of the money that
they make. So the truth of this bankruptcy?
I genuinely have no idea. I think you're right to
be skeptical. As many of you who emailed me are